my god is it dark in here well that's
just part of making a last Navy log it's
two things we're gonna do in this video
I'll go fast I'm gonna tell you the cons
that I'm gonna finish up this year with
and also due next year and then I'm also
gonna do a fast review of Enders game
because Rob is sick and will not be able
to do the sibling rivalry even though it
really sucks cuz I react actually really
did why hear his opinion on this one but
okay so cons first off I got one at mid
December of this year that is con all
tallied and that is from December 13th
to the 15th and that is in the
Chicagoland area really close by so
here's the address on that check it out
we have a lot of channel awesome people
there too like Bryan Hines Malcolm
Rachel are gonna be there
Jason Jory are gonna be there doing the
Adventure Time stuff with me and who
else I think Orlando might be there it
all sorts of people go check it out
gonna be a great time uh
and then next year in February February
7th I'm going to Al makan which is in
Michigan and that is February 7th
through the 9th here's the address for
that no ok here's the thing about that
address it looks like they actually do
not have the website up yet so or it was
up but it got taken Isaac I don't know
I'm sure they're working on the website
so just go to this one until then you
know and just see if they got it up yet
so that's that uh then in May I have mo
Khan and that is going to be from May
23rd the 25th and that is in Atlanta
Georgia and here's the address on that
go ahead check it out I can't remember
if I've been there I think I have at
least two to Atlanta so yeah go check
that out
come see cool fun people all that good
stuff and then I in April I am going to
oh my god how do you say that Zen Chi
Khan I think I'm saying that right
that's from April 25th to 27th that's in
Pennsylvania like here's the address on
that I've heard good things about back
on so I'm definitely looking forward to
that one and
in July from July 4 to 6 I have another
Chicago Con this is actually the same
one I did this year have a great time
it's anime Midwest here's the address
for that again gonna get a lot of our
Chicago people they're gonna get Malcolm
Rachel again and Brian and Jim J Raj Rob
my brother is gonna be there all sorts
of good stuff and then the last one I
got here from July 10th to the 13th
going back to Connecticut
I love this con and you know I know it's
like you're not supposed to say that
like you're not supposed to really
promote one con or the other it's like
your favorite stuff but it kinda is my
favorite I just really really liked it I
really look forward to going back to it
and just always good people at this
kinda gave him more good people because
my brother is coming with he's finally
gonna come to Connecticut
so uh all the cool people I show up
there you're gonna get to finally see
him there so I can have a great time
with that they're already telling me a
bunch of stuff to claim there so really
really excited and that's about all I
got planned for next year in terms of
cons and here's the thing for anyone
that wants to have me at a con maybe in
the winter or fall but honestly before
kinetic on I'm not looking for any
others because I tried cutting my cons
in half and it was still too damn much
so I'm cutting him in half again
but winter and fall they're pretty
available I can do maybe maybe one no
like one or two so if you do I have me
do a con go ahead and contact me
I just can't guarantee anything but you
know still might be possible okay so you
want to hear me talk about Ender's Game
this is a movie that's based on a book
very popular book for a lot kids around
my age growing up and I have not read
the book I'm just gonna put it out there
right now I'm hearing more and more that
makes a big difference so I knew nothing
about this going in sort of the words
being tossed around was Hunger Games in
space yeah kind of but it's definitely
it's a its own thing and from what I
hear Ender's Game came out first anyway
but I mean it's book wise but it doesn't
have it seems like it was me because
Hunger Games was popular so it
movie about human race is almost
destroyed by this alien race and they're
pretty much preparing for if they ever
come back and just building a really
good defense slash offense as we
discover and the people that I guess
aren't the best at the weapons are
learning the weapons and the strategy
are the kids which I didn't totally
follow I'm not saying it's not that like
they don't explain better in the books
or it's not a possibility but they
didn't explain it that well and this it
seems more like hey this is an excuse to
get kids in the story we ought to make
them the focus but whatever they're
Harrison Ford plays this blaze this guy
that this general or commander I forget
um who's looking for a real leader
someone is gonna take the you know take
their armies in and defeat this alien
race
you know once and for all so that
they'll never attack and never almost
never finish the job never kill off
humanity and you have this kid named
ender who is Harrison Ford thinks is the
1i not quite like the Prophet which I
like it's a little bit more like no I
just think he has what we're looking for
it's not as much you are just born the
prodigy you know no there's just some
elements that are good and some that
need to be worked on and let's train him
let's try to make him the best he can be
and see where it goes from here and yeah
it seems very much like the balance of
what's keeping him a child is keeping a
human being and what just makes it this
strategy killing robot and even he
served battling in between them so he
comes across a group of friends that
first are his friends but they grow to
like him and stuff from the sounds of it
it kind of sounds like a generic kind of
kid story that you hear over and over
but I'm gonna be very honest like I've
looked at the Rotten Tomatoes I've heard
other people talk about and people I
don't like it really don't like it at
people I think it's good just kind of
think it's okay I really like this
like I liked it a lot what I really
enjoy about it is I love this kid this
kid I think got that perfect balance
between trying to be a strategist and
something better than you know what he
can even imagine and but not taking that
too far not being a cold-blooded killer
because he has he has a sister that
flunked out because she was too
compassion he has a brother that flunked
out because he was too blood hungry he
was too aggressive and he's kind of the
in-between and he's trying to keep that
balance and he has this extreme fear of
um either of either being too
compassionate or too aggressive and he
shovels it really well and you see the
turmoil of him trying to keep it
balanced as well and Harrison Ford Prima
says I am picking you because I think
you have this extreme potential that you
can really save us and help us out here
and this other person is pretty much
telling you like they should and all
these other very pattern doing whatever
all these other things where it's like
you shouldn't be doing that that's not
where Narnia that's the other one you
know you shouldn't be doing this
you know this is really bad for him
psychologically and they very much make
the argument that what Harrison for is
doing is not necessarily right and that
but but this kid is just trying to make
the best of it and he's trying to be a
good leader he's trying to and he's
doing it because he just knows that's
responsibly what can make him a good
person and what can help the world what
can help you know everything and he goes
through the whole movie like I said
trying to everything is sort of a
strategy Ford keeps putting him in these
situations where he is not given the
advantage or at late put this way by
giving him the advantage he makes him
very unpopular at times like he'll say
something to Harrison Ford and Ford will
be like you know yes good job you're all
gonna have to be better than em yeah
because he's obviously at the top of the
game he wants their kids to hate him so
that a he can learn how to be alone
and/or be he can learn how
win them over and he does that and you
see how he does that
and it's very effective at it's very
smart and it's very strategic and I
think the strategy in this movie is very
strong a lot of the movie is just them
going through sort of this this training
game that they do though I don't know
how it connects to training to fight the
aliens I've yet to see that but it's
just about building strategy and
teamwork and stuff like that that's all
great because the way they shoot it and
the time they take to really show the
movement and they keep on shots and they
don't have it too action-packed you kind
of feel like you're in this room and I
didn't see this in 3d IMAX or heah that
I just saw it on a regular screen and
you really kind of feel like you're
flying in there I'm even weights just
sort of taking his first step like he's
holding on to something he's sort of
letting his feet fly out and kind of
pushing off it it really shows the
process of learning how to be in this
room and how to survive in this game and
and the like I said the weight gets
alongs with the kids the strategy of
getting them along in some he can't get
along with and he you know it goes
possibly too far he doesn't know if he
goes too far I don't know it's I love
that he doesn't ever know if he's going
too far and he has one person Harrison
for this I know no you're doing just
fine and even there he cuts a limit he
says I'm leaving at some point and you
know he finds his way to come back but
he he's getting this power he's getting
the responsibility of the power to me
this is this is the stuff I wanted to
see in Harry Potter
I never realized it but I actually
really wanted to see this in Narnia - I
never you get a little bit in the second
one but it's all just you're the chosen
one
you're the Prophet go do great things
and I don't want to I don't want to oh I
guess I will and don't know this shows
the actual hardship of going through
stuff like this I'm trying to be a good
leader of trying to keep that balance
and I think it does it so effectively
well and I like
the skin I like his teammates I like
these other kids that he's with they had
distinct personalities and they're
likeable they're not just the generics
you know thrown in I mean they have very
distinct personalities and and I want to
see them succeed and whenever they're on
the oh I said whenever that on these
shifts whenever they're anywhere even
though the designs you can't feel like
you've seen before it still feels it
still feels like you're there it still
feels like an environment and it gives
time just to let you be in that
environment I like movies that do that
um
and the effects are very good there is
lots of scenes where you know just a
ship is flying by oh now we're saying
that but I guess how crystal clear it is
um I don't know what they did but I mean
it just looks especially clear in this
movie that a lot of our effects I've
seen and it builds up to this climax
that I I can't go that much into I guess
I'll say this a lot of people not
knowing the books
I'm guessing they did this in the books
but not knowing the books might be
disappointed in the climax it's both
it's both giving you exactly what you
expect and what you don't expect at the
same time and I think they might throw
people off but they put this way there's
a lot of movies where it's like whatever
India Jones you sure you see him going
up against the tank and there's the evil
Nazi guys okay this is the climax you're
about to see the climax and this doesn't
quite work that way it's a little
different so I I admire it for what for
what it does the climax but I think a
lot of people might look at that like
well hey where's where's my sort of real
climax that I wanted my serve good
versus evil it kind of blurs it and I
think it does it in a very clever way
that hasn't really been done because
it's not the standard formula you have
to know going in this is your climax and
you don't in this so I really like they
blur man I like again I like the
responsibility of that of what
not you know gouge anything how to put
this without ruining anything but I like
the choices he makes going into this
versus if he knew something else going
into it and the fact that those choices
actually do make a big difference even
if it's just for consideration I mean
it's just it has to scar this kid for
life because now you know it's like oh
my god if I even like consider this or
thought this I mean even my thoughts
aren't safe and it's oh I'd like I just
really like it and it's putting this kid
through so much but he's also always
rising to the challenge and there's a
there's some times where he bags now but
he thinks he's doing for the right
reason sometimes he is and it's a very
blurred line about whether or not what
he's doing is right but he's not doing
his right what everyone else is doing is
right and it leaves on kind of this
cliffhanger of whether or not a guy I
can't give it away but it does leave on
kind of a cliffhanger
alright era the very Lisa to be
continued and I want to know what's
gonna happen I don't know where it's
gonna go from here and I'm excited to
see where it's gonna go from here the
movie did well so I would love to see a
sequel um whysa I see a lot of people
are giving it very mixed thoughts you
know like they can't get that much
behind it or they feel they seen it
before I haven't seen it before with the
not with this amount of detail or
responsibility to a character really
coming around the the under character
and again the kid does a great job
Harrison Ford finally I'm seeing him in
performance where he's not his teeth out
he doesn't a few times don't get me
wrong but it's not the whole performance
I don't know why it's like after
ordering Crystal Skull it's like you
fell let that way from acting too long I
better really rough and gruff myself up
but what I got okay I got a no and he
was doing that in in Crystal Skull and
Cowboys versus aliens it's just any
movie I see he's just sharted his teeth
out and he doesn't do that too much here
like he actor if he does it's war
rented you know it's not over the top
and I think he does a good job um oh
what the hell is her name
I can't remember her name but the the
the black woman in this who's supposed
to sort of be like you know the mental
stability of these people she does a
great job trying to balance things out
um I think if I had to guess there's one
or two things like little details that
kind of don't always add up there's one
in the ending where if you wanna know
more details look at the bum review
about the ending and you'll kind of see
like wait a minute
and maybe it's explained better the book
that I don't know and it's just a couple
things about the ending that doctor we
add up but it's for me it's worth it
because the story and the development of
the character make the choices made very
interesting so I'll allow sorry these
things that's like way you could have
explained that better um but but there's
like another scene where he's playing
this game with these two glasses that
are poisoned he has to pick one and each
one kills them and when he has to make
another choice he attacks the person
that gives him the two poisons and the
the woman is like you know just oh no
one no kid has ever done this before
bullcrap you know these are these are
kids that as soon as they discover the
guns in the game are like you know it
shouldn't be the shoulder should be the
chance shoot me in the which is a very
boy thing by the way my wife was asking
like why would they do that like that
that's being a boy but yeah there's one
or two things that you sort of go yeah
no but I don't know maybe that's what's
getting away people and maybe the
differences from the book is what's
getting in the way but for me I was so
drawn in by these characters
particularly the main character which I
so rarely see like you know the one
that's supposed to be like the Prophet
or the one to save the day you know just
the good hero is always such a bore and
all the side characters are interesting
like even fans of Harry Potter are like
Harry Harry's a bore we like all the
other characters and this kid is not
this
it reminds me a lot actually reminds me
of the turmoil that like Aang went
through in Avatar it reminds me a lot of
that I felt it really captured that got
just the pain of trying to figure out
what's the right thing to do how to do
it what's the best choice is there even
you know a good choice and it might just
be the you know what's the lesser two
evils so and he has to do that a lot and
he still fights through it and I think
it's just a good strong character and
even at the end he's gonna still try and
see what's the best thing to do and I
admire it a lot I admire that it
actually took the time to try and teach
hard lessons you know not just the
follow your heart be good it's not that
always that easy and I like that it
actually took the time do that even more
than Hunger Games honestly I like this
more than Hunger Games because hunger
games even though I enjoy it is very
much here's our here's our commentary
here's our thing that's obviously bad
and just how people survive in it and
what that's fine don't get me wrong I
love the commentary I love you know the
satire on entertainment and so forth you
know but here's something where it's
really like hey they're gonna go through
some choices are really that they're not
straightforward choices like hey this is
good this is bad most of Hunger Games
you can tell well that person they're
good think that person bit bad think
that's a good guy that's a bad guy and
there's one or two it's like okay that's
just a jerk but even when they are in
there than on there for long um you know
and it gets more into the characters are
more media more interesting and I think
it just did a great job
um and I and I like these characters I
want to see more of these characters it
had good twists and good turns if really
for a movie called Ender's Game it was
mostly the games which I like but it's
not just one game it does sort of go out
and throw new stuff at you and what I
really like is at the very end I'm
saying to myself oh boy there's more
movie and I think I was kind of hoping
it would wrap up soon and it wrapped up
I love you
you know movie ends when it's like I
think it should probably n Mel and it
does it ends on a note where I want to
see more so I really loved it um like I
said I think possibly the the climax
might throw some people off maybe that's
a like I say it's not sort of made what
they thought it was gonna be the
differences from the book could upset
people but could be better you usually
the books are better um like it just
going in as a movie goer just a comment
movie goer I I greatly enjoyed it and I
say if you're looking for a lot of bang
bang shoot them up like for like against
an enemy it's not as much that it's more
like it's kind of like a sports movie
training you to go into that to train
you to go into fighting the actual
villain so it's kinda like half sport
movie hat Star Wars or like starts off
that sports movie it goes into Star Wars
uh and I'm fine with that but a lot of
people might be like an epic one or the
other so yeah hopefully that sort of
gives you an idea whether or not you
would enjoy this or not it's it's not
straightforward it's it's not as much
here's a clear bad guy it's not
necessarily that kind of movie it's not
just this is the Prophet the Prophet
acts good so good things happen the end
it's it might be much more complicated
and far more interesting so I greatly
enjoyed it if you've seen it I hope I
hope you enjoyed it too if not do me a
favor tell me in the comments what what
you didn't like because I'm curious I'm
honestly just curious because like I
said it's sort of getting mixed
reactions and if it's differences from
the book I'll totally understand that
you know it's I'm sure the book does
even more creative stuff or whatever or
it does stuff better but if it's not if
it's something else go ahead and tell me
in the comments cuz I'm actually really
curious I'm curious what people don't
necessarily like about it um and it's
not at all how dare you
now if you don't like it don't like it
but I actually would like to know so um
yeah that's my thought on the movie
hopefully you can give a good idea
whether or not you want to see it and
hopefully I'll see you at some constant
to take care